[Music]
you got a letter from a fan yes and I
want to talk about this this is this a
nice letter it was you know well it's
interesting I mostly I mean I love
interacting with people that enjoy my
comedy on social media you know Twitter
and stuff like that and a case you all
get letters you know when I'm doing
shows and you know occasionally those
letters will be handwritten which is
kind of startling because you know who's
writing by hand unless they're you know
like ninety or a serial killer yeah and
so I got a letter and I'd love to read
it
I ever I have it here and it's you know
it's pretty it's pretty scary so just
here I'll read it this is a real letter
this is a real letter I really got this
hi my name is David I'm just I'm adding
a voice I don't know what the person's
voice I wanted to see you live but my
mom said I was too young to go to the
casino
I also saw your kids video I would have
thrown candy at them we also listen to
you in the car I think you are funnier
than the news
sincerely David PS my dad is fat too
[Applause]
it's pretty scary stuff okay Jim this is
clearly written by a little boy that or
a murderer I mean we don't we don't know
well anyway I you know I had to you know
I wanted to it here's my response dear
David please do not seek to contact me
in the future if you do I'll be forced
to sue your parents and take away your
house you will be homeless I forwarded
your letter to the FBI please do not
attempt to contact me in the future I
know when I'm being stalked love Jim
please find enclosed an autographed copy
of my book dad is fat which is available
at amazon.com and barnesandnoble.com or
on itunes or at a local bookstore all of
these links are available at Jim
Gaffigan
that's I don't know boy I hired a
private investigator you know who this
David was who was David Blaine you're a
terrible liar it's a true story that's
not a true story now you your kids
speaking of your book reviewed your book
yes they did they did before I put them
up for adoption and I have five kids
five kids I'm one of six but that was a
different era that was the late 19th
century big families are like waterbed
stores they used to be everywhere and
now they're just weird yeah now people
don't get it yeah
so we actually have a clip of your
children doing kind of a book they do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's only a fraction of how many
children I have Conan let me ask you a
question in real life you live in a
two-bedroom apartment and you've got
your wife your beautiful wife and five
kids right right well I know we don't
need that much space but it's crazy it's
very it's you know it's a it's it's not
ideal you know I can't walk three steps
without running into one of them and you
know 12 years ago I couldn't get a date
and now there's babies literally
crawling through my apartment it's like
I left peanut butter out or something
but it's crazy